[Musique]
bonjour pour commencer je suis très
patrick sébastien qui disait une petite
pipe avant d'aller se coucher
un petit calumet de la paix aujourd'hui
je reçois jean-hubert hull et jean
hibert bonjour mme hébert donc vous êtes
l'homme le plus pauvre du monde c'est
bien ça faisait deux des bébés comment
devient ton bof justement comment
devient ton bof on rebat comment que
c'est qu'on devient boffard âge et
esprit mal aussi bas c'est un état
d'esprit qu'elle c'est nous qu'on
comprend mieux que c'est nous qu'on
comprend quoi le état d'esprit ok mais
hyper sonic était la première à
remarquer que vous étiez bouffe
ouais le truc qui parle je vois pas
tirer que divers autres
d'accord mais cette fille est beau un
peu vendeuse admettons des détracteurs
rentrer dare etc allez vous disent les
bof c'est nul qu'est ce que vous leur
répondre et les tracteurs ça rentre pas
dans la salle ainsi super gros et je
vois les portes à son super petit ou
alors allez vite on pète les roues alors
on pète le mur mais alors là faut savoir
que si c'est un mur porteur comme l'ont
fait savoir par les inventeurs on tape
ça fait octobre ok c'est super non merci
beaucoup pour votre témoignage
on va faire plus tout est beau pour
évaluer votre niveau vous êtes d'accord
parti mon kiki ou un homme avec les
cheveux longs c'est quoi a plaidé
qu'est ce que vous vous regardez en
premier genivar qu'est ce que vous
attendez d'un chef d'état mais il va
votre chanteur préféré
les prises au lit on dans votre show
auteurs préférés et président du jury
votre plat préféré
hier vous avez des enfants ouais ils
vont en irak c'est possible ça vivront
les acculer d'autres livres préférés ici
votre blague préférée
on a compris stop stop là ça va on a
compris oui mais c'est ce que je dis
depuis le début la vous êtes un pauvre
type enfermé dans votre vie tristar
c'est quoi j'ai pitié de vous super bien
avec moi ah bon moi je pars en vacances
en famille dans le camping pas en
vacances soit derniers mois je fais un
barbecue avec un copain take up a toi
oui mais voilà alors qu'il sait qu'à une
lutte merdes passé moi voilà je le range
et de névrose chez mes peurs qui me
bouffe tous les genres va plus c'est
pour ça que ma femme m'a quitté
c'est un boulot de merde et chuta
épanouie voilà vous avez vous lu gratter
vous avez trouvé la semaine prochaine
devant ce problème le plusieurs
décisions
[Musique]
ainsi si en fait
ça c'est à bully non et s'ils n'ont pas
dispo bravo tu m'as retrouver